Charlamagne tha God here, Lenard McKelvey,
and I am ready to play Most Likely Drew.
(upbeat music)
I mean, it's always like the comedians, right,
especially the women comedians,
you know, Ms. Pat, Tiffany Haddish.
Those are the ones that are really speaking truth to power
in a real way, in a way that you'd be like,
ugh, you'd be uncomfortable.
Like, but that's good.
I can't think of too many female comedians
we've had conversations with where you just don't be like,
I don't know if you're supposed to say that in 2021,
but great content.
(upbeat music)
That's such an interesting question.
A lot of rappers don't like come in the studio
and just be like spitting bars off the top of their head,
or even mumbling to themselves.
You would think that would be the case.
But I don't see that too often.
I have a theory about that though.
I think it's because nowadays a good conversation
can sell records probably better than a good rap can.
So I think when they come to the studio to do interviews,
they're just automatically in that mode of conversation,
as opposed to that mode of performing as artists.
(upbeat music)
Every single rapper you could think of.
I mean, name 'em, like run down the list.
I don't even know the last time a rapper has been on time.
It's like, when a rapper's on time,
you'd be like, oh, okay.
Dope, congratulations.
I'm glad that you decided to show up.
(upbeat music)
Maybe 'cause I just saw her, but Issa Rae.
We had Issa Rae on a couple of weeks ago.
Oh, Ava DuVernay too.
Like Issa and Ava, they just walk in looking very regal.
Very like just everything,
everything put together amazingly
from the shoes to the belt, to the hair, to accessories.
(upbeat music)
Oh man.
I mean, they vary right.
Like I've had the pleasure of interviewing everybody
from President Barack Obama to Young Thug.
And you know, for me, if I'm sitting down with you,
building with you for 40 minutes to an hour, I'm engaged.
Like I couldn't even think
to narrow that down to one person.
We had Dr. Sanjay Gupta on this week
and we built with him for like an hour.
Ed Sheeran was on.
Ed is actually a friend of mine in real life.
Especially when you're talking to people that are really
your folks, like folks you hang out with outside of radio
or podcasts or TV,
folks you actually go to their house and kick it with them.
Those are always very engaging to me
because you don't want to violate the friendship
so to speak.
You don't want to overstep the boundaries of the friendship
because there's things you may know
that you could probably say, but why would you do that?
You know what I mean?
We live in this cancel culture era and you know,
I've been doing radio long enough to know
when somebody may say something
that's gonna get them in trouble.
I'm the type of person now, man, back in the day,
I'd be like, yeah, let that fly.
We put a ratings for the YouTube views, whatever.
But now it's like, nah, let's protect that person.
(upbeat music)
Most improved 100%.
I like who I'm becoming.
I like the journey I'm on.
Going to therapy in 2015-16
was one of the best things that I ever did.
And it just got me on, you know, a healing journey.
For me, it's like, yeah,
I would definitely give myself most improved.
I like who I've become as a man.
It's made me a better father, better husband,
a better friend 'cause I was a wild boy.
Wild boy.
Drew, thank you for having me.
I really appreciated being on the show.
I can feel your energy.
You're a very interesting, unique human
who has an incredible story.
And you've been on quite the journey.
And I just want you to know that the journey is not over
in no way, shape, or form.
You have a lot to offer this world
and you have a lot to offer the universe.
And if I can be of service to you
in any way, shape, or form
Lenard McKelvey, Charlamagne tha God is here for you.
So peace.
(upbeat music)